The first app I ever made was for
a bar crawl, for
a birthday party with a friend.
It was 2009, it was still just
really cool to see your own name in
a smart phone.
So it had a little picker view inside
it, when you shook the phone the picker
view would cycle through everybody who
was there and kind of randomly stop.
And I put a little button int he corner,
so
that you could put your
thumb over it and shake it,
if you're holding it right then it
will come up with the birthday boy.
Whoever's name came up had to drink,
so in the end we could set em up,
it was good fun.
>> The first app I ever built,
well I actually started before there
was an SDK, so in 2007 when
the iPhone came out there was
a pretty good jail break community, and
we were sort of swizzling all the API's.
And I had been an audio developer on
OS10 for years, so I ported one of my
commercial apps to iOS and it was
just super exciting because this was
basically a full desktop operating
system on a mobile device.
So the first app was called Idrum,
and we actually did 23 of them
with different music artists, and
what not and it was really exciting.
We had two of them available
the day the app store opened,
because we had a pretty
good running start so.
>> The first app that I built
was called ATOM and it stood for
the Alpha Tau Omega Mobile application
I built for my fraternity in college,
and as fraternity brothers we were
looking for a way to communicate and
broadcast messages privately in
a way that was kind of like Twitter.
So that's what we did instead of carrier
pigeon, or email or anything like that.
We used this atom map to communicate.